في تطورات تصعيد الاسرائيلي بالضفه
الغربيه افاد مراسل الجزيره بان قوات
الاحتلال اقتحمت بلده يعبد جنوب غرب جنين
وسط اطلاق نار ومواجهات مع شبان البلده
كما اندلعت اشتباكات قويه بين مقاومين
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تخللها القاء
عبوات ناسفه محليه الصنع عقب اقتحام جنود
واليات اليات الاحتلال بلده قباطيه جنوب
جنين بالضفه الغربيه وكانت قوات الاحتلال
قد اقتحمت البلده دهمت احياء عده وفرضت
حصارا
عليها كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بلده بيت جنوبي نابلس في الضفه
الغربيه ونصبت قوات الاحتلال حواجز عسكريه
وسط البلده كما قامت بايقاف المركبات
الفلسطينيه وتفتيشها والتدقيق في هويات
المواطنين وشمال غرب رام الله اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بلده بيت ريما من عده
محاور وسيرت القوات المقتحمه دوريات في
البلده كما قامت بنشر قوات راجله في
شوارعها ينضموا الينا من رام الله مراسل
الجزيره محمد خيري محمد ضعنا في ابرز
الاقتحامات المتكرره ليليا ولكن في هذه
الليله نعم بدايه تتركز الاقتحامات هذه
الليله في مناطق شمالي الضفه الغربيه
وخاصه في مدينه جنين وفي بلده قباطيه في
مدينه جنين هذه ال بلده تتعرض في هذه
الاثناء الى اقتحام اسرائيلي واسع س قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حاصرت قباطيه من جميع
نواحيها ونشرت الحواجز العسكريه وفي هذه
الاثناء هي تسير دوريات وقوات راجله في
عدد من شوارع واحياء قباطيه وقد استحالت
المدينه الى ساحه للمعارك في ظل اشتداد
الاشتباكات بين قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
وكذلك المقاومين الفلسطينيين من داخل
الاحياء الداخليه ل قبطيه تسمع اصوات
اطلاق وتبادل اطلاق النار فعليا وكذلك
القاء عبوات ناسفه محليه الصنع من قبل
الشبان الفلسطينيين وكذلك تحاصر القوات
الاسرائيليه كما قلنا المدينه من جميع
مداخلها في هذه الاثناء وتفرض عليها حصارا
مشددا وهي تداهم عددا من منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين وفي مدينه نابلس ايضا شمالي
الضفه الغربيه وخاصه بلده بيتتا اقتحمتها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من عده محاور
وسيرت دورياتها والقوات الراجله في عدد من
شوارعها وحاصرت عددا من البنايات واقتحمت
عددا من منازل المواطنين الفلسطينيين
واعتقلت عددا من الاشخاص
وكذلك تقوم قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
بيته على وجه الخصوص بايقاف سيارات
المواطنين الفلسطينيين والتدقيق في
هوياتهم وهي بذلك تؤثر على حركه السير في
المدينه وكذلك تربك حركه المواطنين
الفلسطينيين داخل البلده عفوا فيما تشهد
ايضا بعض المدن في جنوبي الضفه الغربيه
وخاصه
منطقه مدينه الخليل اقتحامات اسرائيليه
ايضا واسعه وخاصه في بلده الشيوخ التي
اقتحمتها القوات الاسرائيليه من محاور عده
وكذلك انتشرت في عدد من احيائها وقبل قليل
وردت انباء عن عمليه اقتحام اسرائيليه
ايضا لمدينه قلقيليه شمالي الضفه الغربيه
ايضا وا تشير الانباء المتوفره الى ان
قوات الاحتلال بدات باقتحام المدينه من
عده محاور وهناك ايضا قوات اسرائيليه
توجهت الى بلده عزون ايضا في قلقيليه وهي
تحاصر عددا من البنايات وتسير دورياتها في
عدد من الشوارع يبدو واضحا ان هذه الليله
هي ليله تصعيد اسرائيلي واسع وهو تصعيد
مشابه لكل ليله منذ السابع من اكتوبر وحتى
هذا اليوم حيث تصعد قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من هجماتها على الفلسطينيين في
الضفه الغربيه وحصارها للمدن والمخيمات
والقرى في الضفه الغربيه وكذلك تضاعف عدد
الاعتقالات بشكل واضح جدا يعني نتحدث عن
اعتقالات تجاوزت س
6200 حاله اعتقال في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
خلال اشهر قليله فقط وهو رقم قياسي جدا